In this short overview, I will
discuss App Engine, tell you
what it is, and how it
helps you build applications
at Cloud Scale.
I'm Laurence Moroney, and I'm
a Developer Advocate in Google,
working on the Google
Cloud Platform.
App Engine is an integral part
of the Google Cloud Platform.
This family of technologies
can provide you
with everything you need
to build for the Cloud,
including platform and
infrastructure as a service,
as well as big data, cloud
storage, and much more.
Cloud applications should be
able to scale at a moment's
notice to handle huge or
tiny amounts of traffic.
You should only pay for
the infrastructure capacity
your applications actually use.
When using App Engine, you
can build your applications
to run on top of Google's
world class infrastructure.
You don't have to worry about
provisioning and managing
a data center that scales
to meet your demand.
Google takes care
of all of that.
And you can just
focus on building
the best possible
app for your users.
When developing
for App Engine, you
can use popular languages such
as Python, Java, PHP, and GO,
as well as existing frameworks
like Django and flask.
You can focus on
your code and let
Google worry about database
administration, server
configuration, sharding, load
balancing, and everything else
that you need to build at scale.
You have multiple options
for storing your data,
including relational databases,
scalable file storage,
and a lightweight data store.
App Engine makes
you more productive
by reducing the need to
write boilerplate code.
Manage services such as task
queues, Memcache, and the users
API will help you build
world class applications.
You can use the tools you know,
including Eclipse, Intelliji,
Maven, GIT, and much more.
The App Engine STK allows you
to test applications locally
in a simulated environment.
And they deploy your app
with simple to use tools.
Some of the world's most
popular web services
are built on our platform.
You can scale up to billions
of requests per day,
and scale down when
traffic subsides.
There's lots of great
stuff available to you
as a developer.
And you can learn more about
using them at this URL--
developers.google.com/appengine.
The Cloud is one of the
most important advances
in computer
technology in decades.
App Engine is built on the
same infrastructure that
allows Google to return
billions of search results
in milliseconds, serve over
6 billion hours of YouTube
video per month, and provide
storage for 425 million Gmail
users.
And this scale to your demand.
With free STK's, it's
easy to get started.
And you could be up and
running with building
Cloud applications very quickly.
Companies such as
Snapchat, Rovio,
the makers of Angry
Birds, and Khan Academy
already run an App Engine,
giving their customers
scalable reliable service.
With App Engine,
this infrastructure
is available to you.
And you'll only have to
pay for what you use.
You can learn more about
App Engine at these URLs--
cloud.google.com/product/appengine,
developers.google.com/appengine.
And there's some
terrific samples
to get you started at
googlecloudplatform.github.io.
Thank you.
And welcome to the Cloud.